die frage die sich viele jetzt stellen
es kann der russische überfall auf die
ukraine genutzt werden um dem regime von
wladimir putin ein ende zu machen und
genau darüber diskutieren ab heute auch
hochrangige experten auf einem geheim
gipfel in litauen ja mit dabei sind
geschäftsleute amtierende und ehemalige
spitzenpolitiker sowie menschenrechtler
und journalisten aus europa und den usa
ziel des anti putin gipfels ist zu
klären wie lässt sich der russische bär
erschlagen
eingeladen zu dem treffen hat litauens
aussenminister gabriels landsbergis seit
kriegsbeginn mussten bereits
zehntausende menschen ukrainer und
russen für putins größenwahn sterben in
den vergangenen tagen kamen sogar vakuum
banken zum einsatz
nur atombomben haben eine noch
schlimmere wirkung auch relevant
wladimir putin hat offenbar ein attentat
überlebt
zu dem mordversuch kam es bereits ende
februar kurz nach beginn der invasion
das berichtet die ukrainische zeitung
ukrainska pravda mit bezug auf den chef
des ukrainischen
militärgeheimdienstes gru rudolf rudern
aufs aussagen wurden erst diese woche
bekannt die täter stammen anscheinend
aus dem kaukasus
obwohl das attentat keinen erfolg hatte
wollte der kreml eigentlich nicht dass
die welt jemals davon erfährt
bild-reporter militärexperte juli
also was müssen wir jetzt zu diesem
geheimen anti putin gipfel wissen
ja dieser
gipfel findet jetzt hier seit gestern
nacht statt er hat kurz vor mitternacht
deutscher zeit begonnen wir haben es
hier ein bisschen später und ist
öffentlich wie ihr gesagt habe
tatsächlich ja putin feinde vor allem
aus russland die also zum größten teil
in den letzten jahren bereits verlassen
mussten aber einige leben immer noch in
russland und deshalb müssten sie um ihr
leben und deshalb ist es ebenso hoch
geheim und wir dürfen nicht sagen wer
die sprecher sind wir die teilnehmer
sind fast 100 leute sind hier zu den
russen kommen dazu noch menschen aus
europa auch menschen aus den usa die
eben entscheidungsträger sind und die
eben dabei helfen können bei diesem
geheim gipfel hier in litauen sozusagen
die zeit nach also erstmal das ende
putins und dann die zeit nach putin auch
zu diskutieren er julian der krieg in
der ukraine dauert bereits seit mehr als
drei monaten an was würdest du sagen wer
könnte putin denn letztendlich stoppen
ja also hier wurden verschiedene
szenarien ausgemalt und man hat sehr
große angst aber wo man sich einig ist
putin wird den kreml mit den füßen voran
verlassen ja sagen ja eigentlich alle
eine alternative dazu gibt es nicht der
russische langzeitpräsident der man kann
sagen diktator wird nicht schreiben
nicht von der macht gehen sondern im
rahmen des krieges wird es eben zu sehr
großen problem für ihn kommt wenn er ihn
denn verliert und deshalb ist es ebenso
wichtig dass er ihn verliert das wollt
ihr von allen seiten betont da wird also
nicht so hin und her gesprochen wie in
der deutschen außenpolitik sondern ist
es ganz klar man sagt putin muss diesen
krieg verlieren und dann hat er ein
riesiges problem man hat angst davor
dass sozusagen durch den ja dass es in
einem wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruch
gibt russlands danach eben einen
politischen zusammenbruch wir stellen
uns vor dass geht ja vielleicht noch ein
zwei jahre weiter mit dem krieg das
glaubt man hier durchaus dann gibt s
nicht 30.000 fotos wie bisher von seiner
vielleicht hunderttausend oder 200.000
und dann könnte es einen aufstand geben
von wie man ja angst hat auch vielleicht
ungebildete menschen für menschen die
arm sind interessant könnte zerbrechen
und dass mich niemand sondern man möchte
natürlich hat diesen trauben das muss
dann hero das gesagt zu einer großen
ukraine wird zu einem großen
demokratischen staat auch das ist
natürlich sehr unwahrscheinlich wenn man
sich ansieht was das bereits passiert
und insofern ist das szenario was hier
am ehesten besprochen wird eben dass
putin aus dem eigenen geheimdienst aus
der eigenen elite irgendwann ja einfach
nicht mehr da ist oder irgendwann eben
ein unfall hat oder ähnliches und für
diesen fall glaubt und hofft man
zumindest dass russland irgendwie zu
einer art verfassungsstaat zurückkehren
kann und dann vielleicht auch die vielen
hunderttausend exil russen auch
irgendwann wieder zurückkehren können
allerdings julian gibt es natürlich dann
auch die möglichkeit dass auch putin ein
noch schlimmerer despot folgen könnte
oder zumindest einer denken seiner linie
seine politik einfach weiterführen
ja da muss ich ehrlich sagen das ist ja
auch aufgekommen und die russen hier
sagen tja was soll da noch passieren was
soll da noch schlimmeres passieren
unsere mitstreiter sind im gefängnis
unsere mitstreiter wurden ermordet und
mitstreiter wurden vergiftet wer in
russland ein offenes wort sagt der der
hat gar keine chance und bitte zeigt uns
nochmal die oppositionsparteien hier
noch antreten dürfen also russland ist
eine lupenreine diktatur und die leute
hier ich muss es sagen die russen sind
da offener als wir die vergleichen das
mit dem faschismus unter hitler und sie
sagen
deutschland musste vom faschismus und
von hitler befreit werden russland muss
vom putin ismus und von putin befreit
werden und dann mit dieses volk wieder
zu alter größe sozusagen zurückkommen
kann sie sagen auch russland braucht
dann auch die hilfe braucht eine art
marshall plan wie in deutschland und
europa bekommen haben nach putin und der
muss nicht unbedingt mit ihr geld
eingriff punkt werden sondern vor allem
bezieher demokratisierung also es müssen
wieder medien ja es muss wieder hier
rein politische kultur überhaupt die
kultur des diskutierens ja man sagt ihr
die das russische volk ist unter putin
und auch schon mal vor übrigens in einem
permanenten kriegszustand man hat immer
einen großen gegner man braucht immer
einen großen zeit ansonsten würde dieses
große land zumindest bislang überhaupt
nicht zusammen gehalten werden und man
glaubt ihm dass man sozusagen man nennt
das hier dass das gift des putin ismus
das muss man aus den köpfen sozusagen
der leute leute herausholen und sie
sagen ja es ist wie damals 1945 in
deutschland das muss auch gegen den
willen der menschen aus ihren köpfen
heraus geholt werden damit sie wieder zu
einer demokratischen gesellschaft werden
können nur dann röpke dankeschön für
deine ganze aktuelle einschätzung zu
dieser diskussion
ja und wir wollen diese situation noch
mit zwei weiteren experten besprechen
oberst a d ralf thiele und
verteidigungspolitiker florian hahn von
der union sind uns jetzt zugeschaltet
einen schönen guten morgen
die erste frage die ziele welche
militärische gefahr geht davon aus wenn
putin verschwindet
also ich habe noch gute jahre damals bei
gc sind straßen büro des
oberbefehlshabers über haben
aus der sorge ist so eine zerfallende
großmacht mit nuklearwaffen aber auch
mit biologischen chemischen kampfstoffen
damals die sorge könnte das zu gaddafi
nach syrien gelangen würden die
wissenschaftler darüber gehen es gibt ja
auch andere despoten heute die sich
bedienen könnten aus russland sicherlich
hat der westen guten grund sich sorgen
zu machen über so ein plötzlich
zerteilen ist russland damals haben sich
die usa sehr engagiert das alles in
irgendeiner form zu stabilisieren ich
kann mir das nicht anders vorstellen das
wäre heute nicht anders und deutschland
wird natürlich mitmachen
wie kann deutschland denn sich jetzt
positionieren in dieser situation was
sollten wir jetzt tun
naja wichtig ist tatsächlich eine
situation zu erzeugen die es ganz
deutlich macht dem kreml dass er keinen
erfolg haben kann ich irgendwie ähneln
so weit sind geladen aber auch nicht und
deswegen ist es auch wichtig jetzt
wirklich nicht nur ansprachen und reden
zu halten sondern tatsächlich auch im
wahrsten sinne des wortes zu liefern in
dem fall gerade aus deutschland schwere
waffen und das ist ja alles sehr
zögerlich und wir sehen mit der
situation wenn gerade in dornbach die
ukraine ist gerade schwer unter druck
die russische föderation kann hier
einige
tatsächlich gebietsgewinne unterzeichnen
und es ist wirklich steht spitz auf
knopf deswegen wird's höchste zeit was
würden sie sagen welche rolle spielt
unsere bundeswehr und auch unsere
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht in
dieser diskussion herr thiele
leider keine ich muss auch dazu sagen
ist ja nun schon wirklich lange lange
her dass wir sie bis auf die unterhose
ausgezogen haben mit beitrag uns alle
relevanten politischen parteien in
deutschland
das heisst also jetzt dieser nackte man
kann auch keine großen beiträge leisten
natürlich kann er mehr tun als bisher
ich bin da doch er perplex dass jetzt
drei monate krieg sind und tatsächlich
wieder munitions bestände aufgefüllt
wurden noch verträge mit der industrie
geschlossen worden und das hat natürlich
dann auch ein rückkopplungseffekte auf
die ukraine wie wir die 100 stützen
können sei es ein ringtausch mit anderen
europäischen oder nato partnern also
hier ist einfach viel mehr sinn für
dringlichkeit gefragt herr hahne vor
lamprecht jetzt auch auf diesem anti
putin gipfel nicht mit dabei ist das
jetzt das richtige signal hat sie wieder
sozusagen eine chance verpasst etwas
richtig zu machen in ihrem amt
also ich weiß nicht ob das so zu sagen
der richtige ort ist aber sie hat
genug andere dinge zu tun und da ist sie
aber nicht alleine sondern schlicht die
bundesregierung insgesamt vor allem auch
der bundeskanzler dessen zögerliche
haltung ich einfach nicht nachvollziehen
kann es gibt die regierung widerspricht
sich auch bei der frage was man denn
jetzt mit welchen partnern wo ausgemacht
welche waffen geliefert werden können
partner beschweren sich wie die polen
beispielsweise dass der angestrebte
linktausch nicht funktioniert also da
ist wirklich chaos und ich frage mich
langsam ob das ideologische
hürden sind die tatsächlich verhindern
dass wir endlich schwere waffen an die
ukraine liefern denn anders kann ich mir
das nicht vorstellen dass es keine
schlamperei sondern das ist inzwischen
auch nicht fahrlässig sondern
offensichtlich vorsatz dann würden sie
sagen unsere verteidigungsministerium
müsse zurücktreten
nochmal also ich glaube nicht dass das
wahr lamprecht alleine ist ich bin
schwer insgesamt von der bundesregierung
jetzt endlich taten statt worte und
wissen sie mir ist das egal ob das man
da jetzt
politisch
einen rücktritt fordert oder nicht das
hat jetzt geht es hier um tatsächlich
leib und leben und der ukraine endlich
was tun das sind die entscheidenden
dinge es geht aber dann auch wenn wir
uns jetzt gerade um diesen anti putin
gipfel noch mal kümmern auch um eine ja
eine zukunft dieser welt und auch
europas und auch russland ohne putin
glauben sie dass frau lambrecht die
richtige kandidatin wäre um diese
zukunft tatsächlich mitzugestalten
trauen sie ihr das zur rtl
ja ich würde die frage der in richtung
bernburg weitergeben tatsächlich ist das
eher ein größeres thema als nur die
ukraine weil wir auch mit china zu tun
haben die eine sehr große
einwirkungsmöglichkeiten hat das land
oft russland das auch ein sehr
geschädigt über die ganzen konsequenzen
für die weltwirtschaft ist von daher
würde ich mir wünschen frau berg während
bickel gerichte sagen ja vielen dank für
diese einordnung erziele reif thiele und
der verteidigungssprecher florian hahn
von der cdu
gerne danke ja und darüber möchten wir
sprechen mit bildpolitik chefreporter
peter tiede hier bei uns im studio und
wird also über möglichkeiten diskutiert
peter über einem russland ohne putin
kann man sich das überhaupt vorstellen
wer das sägen oder er vielleicht ein
fluch es gibt ganz viele leute die sich
das lebhaft vorstellen können aber die
frage ist ob das realistisch ist und
selbst wenn wladimir putin weg wäre dann
wäre das system nicht weg wladimir putin
ist teil eines systems als kopf eines
systems und ist eine kopf hektar wächst
plant nach das ist eine hydra also von
daher man kann sich darüber gedanken
machen auf so einem gipfeltreffen ob wie
eine welt ohne wladimir putin aussehen
kann aber ich glaube es geht nicht so
sehr darum zu gucken wie man putin
wegkriegt das ist aufgabe der russin das
ist eine innere angelegenheit das müssen
die mit sich selber klären das ist die
frage wie kann man diesen krieg beenden
und dann quasi russland aus der ukraine
herausbekommen also die puccini sieren
das ist die spannende frage an der
ganzen sache aber wer wer russland
kritisiert das müssen die russen bitte
sich weitgehend selber selbst ausmachen
und da wurde seit 20 jahren darüber
diskutiert oder seit 15 jahren oder zehn
jahren immer wenn ein russen herrscher
dran ist der aggressiv ist dann wird
überlegt wie man den weg bekommen kann
das können und müssen die russen dank
mit sich selber ausmachen peter unsere
fdp-politikerin marie agnes strack
zimmermann fordert weiterhin vehement
waffen wie schätzt du da sein das ist
wirklich eine der der forderung die
tatsächlich auch in zielführenden führen
können und die man nach drei monaten
krieg ja fast nicht mehr hören kann wir
haben zum anfang des krieges haben wir
verweigert das auch nur panzerhaubitzen
die mal der ddr gehört haben von island
in die ukraine gilt geliefert werden
jetzt ist man immerhin so weit dass man
abwehr panzer schickt aber kampfpanzer
schickt man nicht das einzige was die
ukraine momentan braucht es nicht ein
gedankenspiel darüber wer künftig mal im
kreml sitzt sondern da
wie sie sich verteidigen können und sie
hätten seit wochen seit monaten schwere
panzer gebrauchen können kampfpanzer
gebrauchen können jetzt sind sie im don
was eingeschlossen teilweise stehen an
einigen stellen mit dem rücken zur wand
weil die russen hals des kriegs mit
immer mehr verkleinert haben und damit
eine konzentration ihrer eigenen truppen
hinbekommen haben und da gehören waffen
hin die hätten schon längst da sein
müssen tat frau stark zu machen absolut
recht dennoch müssen wir schon noch mal
ein bisschen über die rolle von putin
von russland sprechen und eben auch über
ein mögliches zukunftsszenario wie
daneben tatsächlich die weltordnung
aussehen könnte wenn putin irgendwann
den kreml verlässt ob in den füßen nach
vorne oder eben nicht wäre es denn auch
möglich dass tatsächlich jemand an der
macht kommt dass er jemand wartet der
eigentlich noch viel schlimmer ist als
putin weil weniger bekannt weniger zu
kontrollieren in dem fall oder ist dass
jedes szenario was sagt ok putin ist weg
ist ein guter mit dieser frage
beschäftigen die russen und oder die
sowjets die welt seit fast 100 jahren
bei jedem sowjetherrschaft russen
herrscher irgendwie da war wurde immer
dem westen gegenüber mit der frage
gespielt und ökologie da kommt er
dennoch einer der ist ja vielleicht
sogar noch schlimmer das ist nicht
unsere frage es ist unsere frage wie wir
mit einer welt klar kommen in der ein
solches russland existiert wo ein system
herrscht das nicht nur an die
demokratisch ist sondern das der
tyrannische und diktatorisch ist und das
andere völker überfällt damit müssen wir
uns auseinandersetzen nicht nicht werden
also wir müssen nicht diskutieren wir im
kreml regiert wir müssen überlegen wie
wir damit klarkommen werde im kreml
sitzt und dass da eigentlich
bürokratisches mafiöses krieger system
an der macht ist und
die frage muss man dann eines tages
einfach nur den russen überlassen die
müssen sich entscheiden ob sie damit
leben wollen dauerhaft ja oder nein ich
schätze dass ein momentan die stimmung
im volk hatte putin hat einfach den hat
er den rückhalt und dabei ist die maus
keinen faden ab da können wir uns offen
gekommen wir können wir kopfstände
machen dieser mann sitzt relativ fest im
sattel ihn was bei der bevölkerung die
andere frage ist ob ihm sein eigenes
system noch trägt aber auch dann dann
ist da die mir putin weg und dann kommt
ein anderer dann müssen wir mit dem
umgehen vielleicht ist der moderator
vielleicht will der ukraine krieg dann
halt beenden zu anderen konditionen als
wladimir putin bereit ist aber
vielleicht aber wir müssen mit den
tatsachen umgehen mit dem was momentan
da ist und uns nicht den kopf der russen
zu brechen
bild reporter julian röcke der nämlich
vor ort in litauen ist julian größte
geheimhaltungsstufe aber kannst du uns
von den ersten ergebnissen berichten
ja die ersten ergebnisse hier sind ja
man ist sich relativ einig also sie mit
etwas schief die teilnehmer hier sind
zum größten teil aus russland ich würde
sagen so 70 80 prozent sind aus russland
die anderen 20 aus europa eben vor allem
aus litauen aber auch aus anderen
ländern und aus nordamerika und
man ist ja eigentlich das ja also dass
hier bis putin da man braucht ein
russland ohne putin da ist man sich ja
eigentlich natürlich wie peter richtig
sagen den weg dahin kennt man auch nicht
man glaubt aber dass dieser tipp
dass nicht nur dynamik entwickelt die
unter umständen dafür sorgt dass putin
ihr habt doch schneller schneller den
können wir verletzt als er denn
eigentlich wollte
danke juliane für den moment der pkw
schätzt du dieses treffen ein
das ist das notwendig dass sich
bestimmte kreise halter heiterer
vorbereiten also auf eventualitäten und
durchgehend was ist eigentlich wenn
welt verändern wird wird wird das nicht
sein aber es ist halt für eine bestimmte
szene für die leute die sich damit
beschäftigen und diese szenarien
entwickeln darüber wie man mit russland
umgehen kann oder wie man bestimmte
kräfte in russland stärken kann ist dass
wir wie wichtig aber wir dürfen eines
nicht vergessen ja aus russland raus ist
ist aus dem bewusstsein der bevölkerung
aus das haben die sozialistischen system
und die diktaturen immer so gemacht das
hat die ddr so gemacht wäre richtig toll
gestört hat ist einfach ins ausland
abgeschoben und der dürfte ausreisende
ist quasi verbannt worden und damit
waren sie weg außer ddr öffentlichkeit
michael kolakowski garri kasparow die
köpfe für uns im westen des widerstandes
gegen wladimir putin die spielen in hand
keine rolle und das ist so also es wird
keiner putin nach folgen können ja
irgendwie aus dem exil kommen oder
irgendwo hatte da ist ein festes system
der geheimdienst das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen in russland hat der
geheimdienst den staat mit putin
übernommen es ist ein system mit der
silowiki so heißt das das sind leute aus
dem geheimdienst und aus der wirtschaft
die das übernommen habe und außer mafia
und wenn ein kopf abgeschlagen dann
kommt ein anderer mag sein dass der
moderator ist mag sein dass er hertha
ist das alles muss für uns keine rolle
spielen so lange wie der westen dann
geschlossen stehen würde und mit dem
umgeht und sagt mit so einem russland
reden wir nicht verhandeln wir nicht und
handeln wir nicht dann wäre viel dann
wäre viel geholfen der ukraine wäre
momentan geholfen wenn deutschland eine
klarere position einnehmen würde wenn
wir tatsächlich schwere waffen liefern
würden und nicht nur uns zu tode
diskutieren würden aber da können wir
leider momentan nicht helfen wir haben
die bundesregierung die wir haben damit
umgehen dass wir im kanzleramt der
bestimmte sachen nicht will
damit muss die welt leben und leider
auch die ukraine haben wir wollen mal
einmal anhören was unser bundeskanzler
olaf scholz jetzt gerade in zu diesem
thema gesagt hat in davos
und die brutalität des russischen kriegs
hat die ukraine und china als nation
enger zusammengeschweißt putin darf
seinen krieg nicht gewinnen und ich bin
überzeugt er wird die nicht gewinnen
russlands überfall auf die ukraine
markiert nicht den ausbruch irgend eines
konflikts irgendwo in europa hier nimmt
eine nuklear hochgerüstete großmacht für
sich den anspruch grenzen neu zu ziehen
peter ganz kurz noch dazu eine nuklear
hochgerüstete großmacht das ist ein
wedding was sonst so nicht benutzt wird
oder also es ist eine nuklearmacht ja
sich der chor ist eine militärische
großmacht ja ist eine grosse armee aber
eine großmacht russland ist keine
großmacht russland ist unter waldimir
putin verstärkt worden es ist ein
wirtschaftlicher zwerg und politisch
okay sie haben den sitz im
un-sicherheitsrat das macht sie wichtig
aber eine großmacht zeichnen ganz andere
sachen aus wladimir putin hat gross
macht streben wladimir putin möchte sein
land zur großmacht machen und was macht
unser bundeskanzler tut ihm den gefallen
und nehmt sein land so war das ein
lapsus ist etwas einfach so
rausgerutscht hat er da nicht drüber
nachgedacht oder hat er das irgendwann
hintergrund das glaubst du das ding ist
aufgeschrieben worden das ist eine
geschriebene rede gibt gibt ein
redemanuskript das hat jemand damit
absicht reingeschrieben und nuklear
hochgerüstete großteils eine großmacht
mit also großmacht plus nuklearwaffen
das war mit absicht peter danke schön